the agenda for today is
what is kubernetes right so i'm i'm
gonna
assume that you either heard about
kubernetes or at least uh um
have
seen someone or an organization that
uses kubernetes but in this workshop i'm
going to assume that you've never used
kubernetes right so
um the idea is to start from scratch so
what we're going to do
um the way that this workshop works is
we're going to set up an environment on
aws that's why the there there was a
prerequisite of having an aws account
and we're going to use cloud9 which is
like a virto uh developer environment
for aws so we're going to deploy a
cloud9 instance and use that to deploy
our cluster right
uh so
we're going to understand what is
kubernetes the kubernetes architecture
right i'm gonna talk about all the small
components uh um
the the two main components the the
control plane and the worker nodes and
then the each little component that's
inside those those major ones
um as jeff said we're going to do some
crap modeling right i don't know if you
heard but
this year in april this year the mitre
released the attack framework the attack
matrix for containers right
and
we were part of this this work with
miter right so we partnered with mitre
when they
uh when they did this uh when they
called the community for help and and we
provided some data regarding our uh our
honeypots we have some docker and
kubernetes
that we use to analyze uh attack data on
those environments so we're gonna talk
about that as well
um then later we're going to talk about
well after we
set up our environment on on aws we set
up a cluster we're going to deploy a
application uh a container contourize
application there a vulnerable
application and so we're going to attack
it right so we're going to understand
what's going on uh um how can an
attacker compromise the cluster one of
the many ways that uh that's possible
and of course this is a misconfigured
cluster right so that you understand the
fundamentals of why it's important to
keep your kubernetes cluster uh well
configured and secured
and if we have time then we're going to
talk about defending kubernetes right so
what are the main uh issues on
that you can like what are the best
practices right
either regarding the api server and the
whole uh process of deploying in a
container uh generating a container
right from scratch and and deploying it
into a kubernetes cluster and and there
is many things that we can talk about
here
so yeah i hope you enjoy and and feel
free to ask questions i know that people
are monitoring those questions and and
they can send them over to me so if
you're struggling if you're not if
you're you're trying to follow along and
something's not working for you don't
worry try feel free to ask questions and
i can we can make this uh
very interactive
okay
so
before we start i just want to say that
i um since i started working with
kubernetes uh
last year
i created this this kind of github
project the awesome kubernetes security
list
and um this project has
um has like a bunch of links and and
information that i use myself to learn
kubernetes and understand and has a lot
of stuff about kubernetes security so
let me share that here
with you so that you can take a look as
well so yeah first this uh um i started
with that as a like a kind of my own
thing when i was studying saving links
on a
text file uh for myself but i said no
maybe maybe some people other people can
benefit from that as well and and that's
why i did this this github repo which
has almost
almost a thousand stars already right
and i created that in october last year
so it hasn't been even over a year yet
and has a lot of information i know
there's some stuff that i need to update
and i'll update it soon so
so yeah feel free to start to fork it
and if you have any other links that are
either related to kubernetes or
kubernetes security you can submit a pr
to me and then i'll take a look and add
to the list as well so there's a lot of
information here
okay so i'll give an overview of about
what is kubernetes so that you can
understand and then we go to set up the
environment and now continue the slides
while the environment is setting up
because it takes a few minutes to set up
the environment on aws
so yeah let's let's do that first
so what is what is kubernetes right so
what is your understanding of kubernetes
if you have uh if you have seen it if
you have used it right
yes kubernetes is an open source system
for automating deployment scaling and
management of contourized applications
right and and but what does that mean
right
if you remember when docker was released
in 2013 right um there was a lot of uh
hype about using docker and using
containers and and
containerizing everything right
but quickly we learned that by doing
that
there was a lot of
uh
it increases the overhead of management
of those applications right because when
docker was released there was no way for
you to
easily manage
multiple multiple containers running on
multiple servers right and
and so kubernetes was was created
as an idea to help manage those
containerized applications right so it's
a no
a container orchestrator as we say it
right
and um they just released the latest
version which was 1.22 right and it has
um before like uh until last year was
new versions were released four times a
year so kind of every quarter and i
think now it's three times a year so it
gets updated very quickly right so you
need to
follow along and keep yourself updated
so that you also can uh keep your
cluster updated right um so some of uh
quick facts and fun facts about
kubernetes here
it was created by google right in 2014
and it's based on uh on internal
projects
from google which are called borg and
omega right which are closed source
right and they they decided to google
has been used containerized applications
for for uh many years now and that's why
they worked on this project
kubernetes means uh
it's a word from greek which means
helmsman right and helmsman is like the
the person who kind of drives the ship
the ship right a big ship and in kind of
a
allusion to docker which are or the
containers right and the person kind of
steering the wheel of the ship there
that's that's the helmsman right
um
sometimes can be the captain sometimes
it's another person so that's why um
and that's another reason why the icon
for kubernetes is a helm right that's
what we call this kind of steering wheel
of a ship right and it's a helm
um
yeah uh another fun fact burku brunei's
is it's also called gates right k a s
and the reason for that is just because
there is eight letters between k the k
and the s of of kubernetes right if you
count the letters there in between the
you bernati it's eight letters so that's
why an abbreviation of that um that's
the why the way that they do it
um
another thing kubernetes developed in go
golang right it's as same as docker and
many other um
cloud native applications as well
so
yeah
okay
let's move on
uh why kubernetes right so since since
it's important to understand what bernat
is is it's also important to understand
why kubernetes like should you use
kubernetes in your organization right
you don't want to go
go to your company on on monday and say
no we should move everything to
kubernetes because kubernetes is the
next big thing right
um there is a lot of uh
a lot of management required to run
kubernetes clusters right and and as i
said like i think personally from my
perspective it's a very complex system
it's hard to understand and especially
if you don't have the the background of
what kubernetes
do in behind the curtains right so once
you understand that that gets easier to
to know what it's doing but but it's
like
you need to have that background right
so yeah just a kind of a a
a comic here from gilbert right it's not
everything that needs to be okay
kubernetes right doesn't mean like that
it's
the you have uh
very few people that really really
understand kubernetes properly
especially even kubernetes security and
and yeah it's
if you want to
start moving your applications to your
kubernetes cluster then you're going to
require not just
uh
budget right resources to do that but
also uh skilled people to maintain your
clusters right so
uh and think about that before you go
into okay yeah let's let's move
everything to kubernetes it might not be
uh the solution and it might not be uh
required for your needs and your
organization needs
okay
uh what is the cncf right the cncf is
the cloud native computing foundation
it's the foundation
uh uh it's a sub foundation of the linux
foundation
it helps and maintain many different
projects from uh what they consider
cloud native right
so kubernetes is just one of them there
are many different others that you can
see here and some of them are even part
of kubernetes as fcd and core dns and
also helm to to
package
kubernetes applications as well so
there's many different ones right so it
doesn't mean just kubernetes when we're
talking about cloud native uh since yeah
the cloud native computing foundation
and cloud native security we're not just
talking about kubernetes right this is
the on the url there at the bottom the l
dot cncf.io if you go there it's going
to show you a lot of uh different
projects that are related to cloud
native right and just a quick thing here
about um what what means to be a cloud
native right doesn't mean that the
application only runs in the cloud right
and we're going to talk probably going
to talk about that in the next few
slides but just
just to add to that
um being cloud native is is there's
different characteristics and
applications that they uh they have and
they're more they're they're they're
created to run in cloud native cloud
environments but they can also run on
premises right there are there are
organizations and and many different
companies that run kubernetes on
premises right okay
yeah so
that's the slide here as i said like
what what it means to be cloud native
the definition here it's from the cncf
itself and can be found on their github
and basically uh um as they say to a
cloud to an application to be cloud
native he needs to have this
characteristics on the left your seven
characteristics and some examples here
that you probably are using or you
probably heard about right containers
service meshes micro services in general
immutable infrastructure or
infrastructures code and declarative api
so these are some examples of cloud
native applications
okay
okay so i'm going to stop here before i
go into the architecture and explain
all the details i'm going to share my on
my screen and and try to uh
have everyone follow along to set up
their environment okay
so let me stop sharing let's see if it
can
oops i can share again one second
okay
okay
okay can you see my screen yeah good
so the uh one of the prerequisites of
the workshop
as we mentioned he's having an aws
account right so
go uh if you are not logged in on your
aws account please go ahead and log in
and and what we're gonna do as i said
like we're going to
deploy a
a cloud9 instance right which is this
service from aws and we're going to find
out very soon how it works it's
basically an online version of vs code
so if you use vs code before you're
gonna find it very easy to follow along
and from that right the idea of why why
i'm using this right the idea is that i
want to make sure that everyone has the
same environment right and so if you're
using i didn't want to like create a vm
and deploy and send it to you to
download and everything let's let's do
it online right and using cloud9 is a
good way to everyone is going to have
the same environment if we use the same
configuration here and then from there
we we can set up the instance to deploy
the cluster uh afterwards right once we
have the cloud magnets set up and that
takes uh that's that very quickly
but then we configured the cluster on
aws as well
so
okay let's start here and i'm going to
create one from scratch i have some
created here but i'm going to create a
new one
so
let's see cloud
out village right
workshop
so nate the name you can can give any
name that you want right just so just
remember if you have different uh cloud9
instances
but yeah you can add a description as
well
here
you have the settings of the environment
of your cloud9 is it's going to deploy
an ec2 right so the way that cloud9
works it's deploying an ec2 but it's
going to configure it that's going to
work as an online developer developing
platform right so it's basically online
vs code that's hosted on aws so that you
have
uh uh all your code there if you want
you can use that as well
um so yeah basically it's going to
create a new ec2 environment right the
idea here you can use t2 micro right
um which is free
uh three tier if you have it here um
yeah just another note here before
before we move on
there might be some charges because not
because of this cloud9 but once we
deploy the cluster and eks and
everything
uh depending on how long you leave the
cluster online there might be some small
charges on on on your
credit card on your account right but
but at the end of the workshop i'm going
to show how to remove everything so that
you don't leave anything uh running and
and don't get charged a lot of money
okay
sounds good
okay so here if you're out there
um basically we're going to create a new
c2 instance i i'm it doesn't matter like
i don't need that large instance for the
cloud9s because i'm only dealing with
code and executing some commands there
so that's fine
the platform can be uh
amazon linux 2
and i can leave this everything default
here after the 30 minutes of uh idle
time if i'm not using the cloud9
instance
uh it's going to shut down
automatically here so i can leave
everything here
as it is right by default
and i'm on the right region yeah i'm on
u.s east one so i'm going to deploy it
on usc 1. the cluster i can deploy
anywhere and and we're gonna see how to
do that but basically for the cloud9
instance make sure that everyone is on
the same uh uh uh same region and they
have this access to the same features
right that's that's the only uh the only
reason for that
okay here just uh um an overview of of
the settings that i set up basically
everything is default right now
uh we're going to create a new row for
for uh my instance later but let's do
let's leave it at that right now
okay so it's it's creating my
environment it might take a few seconds
two minutes right
and this is going to be like if you use
vs code before if you work with
coding in and programming in vs code
you're going to find it very interface
is very similar there is a few things
that we need to do here
um once the environment is set up
and and so creating an iem uh row for
our instance and also disabling some
credentials so i'm gonna show here once
the cloud nine is is completed and and
deployed right
um let me see
see if it's taking a lot of time
yeah let me go back
um yeah if i have um i don't know if we
have any questions so far
but yeah feel free to ask them if you're
stuck if you
if you're like you missed something uh
until now
feel free to send the questions over
through the the form the google form
okay no question sounds good awesome
thank you
so yeah let's let's let me wait here
once okay now the client name cloud9
instance is set up
as you can see it's basically an ide
platform
online
i have a terminal here um i can add new
files and new terminals as well right
okay
so what we're going to do i mean
new terminal
okay
is the font good enough
uh for everyone to see
i don't need maybe
let's leave it at that okay
so this is basically the environment
that we're going to use
to uh
deploy our cluster from right
okay so a few things that we need to set
up here and i'm going to show you
is oops
sorry it's on this
settings here on the top right corner of
my uh
interface there's
a gear icon called preferences right
and in this gear icon i need to go to
aws settings
and on the aws settings i'm going to
disable this aws manage temporary
credentials right all i need to do is
click here and disable that
and that should be fine
okay
everyone got that
preferences go to aws settings and
disable the aws manage temporary
credentials
good
so after that
um
let's see
let's now we're going to
uh
let's let's let's create the now we're
going to back go back to the aws console
to create
to create
uh uh the iem role that i need to give
to this
uh ec2 instance because the cloud9 is an
easy to instance to be able to have
permissions to to deal to talk to eks
and create clusters
yes the workshop is going is being
recorded and it's going to be shared
later as well
so yeah
fine
okay let me go back to
the aws console here let me open another
tab
and i think i need to share
stop sharing this one and share the
other one sorry about that
[Music]
okay
so yeah on oops
i think i'm in the console yeah
on aws console what we're going to do is
create an imro and and
please don't do this on your
production account because what we're
going to do is create an iam role with
uh
administrator permissions administrator
privileges
so that we can give um
can give the cloud9 instance permissions
to create the cluster and everything
right so that we don't have any issues
we don't face any issues we're going to
give this administration a role so i'm
going to iam and let me let me go back
so what i did was okay i went to iam
which is the
the identity and access management uh
service from aws
and basically what we're going to do is
create a row
for that
create row
i go here to rows on the left side and
create row
and here i select
aws service that's selected by default
ec2
okay
and then i click next in permissions
under permissions it's going to load and
i'm going to give this role
administrator access to my account right
so be very careful with that don't use
that in in a production environment i we
don't want that because that's too
permissive right i don't want to give
that idm role this is just for the
workshop so that we don't
don't have any issues deploying the
cluster
uh you can add tags but that's not
needed
and row name
[Music]
c9 i'm gonna do cloud cloud9
instance row okay
you can put any name just remember that
name because you need to attach that
to your cloud9 instance okay
so what i did was just
repeating what is what i did was i went
to iam i went to row and create a new
row selected ec2 and gave the policies
administrator access and created a name
for it right that's it
okay the role the role has been created
so the next thing that i need to do
is go back to
i'm going to the ec2 now
and attach that row to my
easy-to-instance my cloud982 instance
right
so i'm going to ec2 here that's why i
tap ec2 and okay to see my machines
running i see that there is an instance
running make sure that you're in on the
same region that you deployed your
cloud9 instance
and basically
see there is this instance running here
that's that's why i i have the cloud9
running as well
so select the instance here the ec2 and
uh on actions
security
modify iim roll okay
that that's going to
uh
we're going to attach that row that we
just created to distance list
so again select my instance go to
actions security and modify iam row
and here i have my row that i just
created the cloud9 instance row
and i'm gonna give it i'm gonna attach
that to the instance and i'm going to
save
okay
if you got
uh get this message so successfully
attach your role to the instance that's
that's great that's wha
all we need so far
um
is is anyone
uh behind does anyone have any questions
anyone struggling with something feel
free to ask okay
so now that i set this up
i need to
go back to the cloud9
and install a few things on my cloud9
instance
to
be able to deploy the cluster right so
some things i'm going to install
is a
cube ctl
some some other packages so we're going
to follow along let me share that with
you
let's see if i have it here
uh
okay
yes let me share my s let me go back to
my cloud9 this is because i'm not
sharing that
yeah
sorry for this switching here but
i don't wanna show any
any sensitive information right
yeah okay
so i'm here
one of the things that i need to do here
on the cloud nine i've attached remember
if you haven't done the aws settings
right disable that as well just let me
show it again
right the temporary credentials
and
yeah okay so you can see that there is a
kind of a directory structure here it
shows your environment i can have many
uh terminals and all that stuff that's
great
so
now we're going to
um
use this
this project on github and and
to download two files that that's all i
need to set up my cluster basically off
and i'm going to install uh some some
package and some tools but basically
those two files it's all i need to set
up my cluster um
so let me show you here we clone and
this url the kubernetes sac 101 workshop
if you download that
you can see that there's basically two
files there and i'm going to explain
what they are so
i'm going to
increase the font
and close this i don't think we're going
to need this okay
show it here
and yeah
so you can see that there is two files
here two yml files right and if you
haven't played with yaml before that's
that's something that uh kubernetes uses
a lot
right to um
to manage uh to deploy applications and
objects on kubernetes right they're all
usually yml files that
that turn into json or send to the
kubernetes api server and i'm going to
explain that soon
um
if you haven't cloned this so the
command is git clone let me post the
whole command there git clone
uh i'll share it with the um
the people participating and
yeah if you clone that if you have those
two files on your
on your cloud9 instance you're good okay
so far you're good let's let's let's
move along
so now
uh um this this cloud9 instance is brand
new right so i don't have if i try to
use pube ctl which i'm going to explain
some what it is but it's basically a cli
to
talk to your kubernetes cluster um
so i don't have that right now right
command not found that's not installed
so i need to install that
so the first command to install um
cubectl is this one here let me
see uh okay
let me post that on the chat
and so this is the first command here
and i'm going to share with you so
basically i'm downloading that uh from
aws and see if that's done
okay
so now i should have
uh oh i need to give it permissions of
course
the second command is to allow execution
permissions to this binary right keep
ctl and don't worry i'm going to explain
everything once we once we start
deploying the cluster which is the thing
that takes uh longer then we go back to
the slides and i'm going to explain some
things that i'm doing here if you may
not uh if you're not uh
able to understand yet but you you will
be able to understand the words
okay let's see
yeah so cuba city always working right
we have that already now keeps intel
controls the kubernetes cluster manager
that's great
um other things that we can install
that's gonna help you um
with our
interaction with the cluster so let's
start a few a couple packages
um that can help you in and those
packages are jku and and get tags and
batch completion right so basically what
i'm going to do is sudo uh yum style
those packages right because they don't
have that on the
on the cloud9 instance by the phone
great
now i'm going to
uh configure
a batch completion to keep ctl so that
helps me when i'm
managing my cluster and using commands
with with cubectl
so basically cube ctrl completion bash
bash completion
and um
another one here
i mean oops
let me post those two commands to the
team as well so they can share with you
yeah
okay so those are two separate commands
that you're doing and let me
let me clear here so that i move this
down okay that's better
um okay any any questions so far anyone
struggling any comments that you don't
understand
there's just a couple more things that
we're going to do now we're going to
install eks ctl right and and what eks
ctl is
is a a another binary to interact and
and help you deploy eks clusters right
and what is dks eks is the manage
kubernetes services from aws
right so it's
it's like a a kubernetes that's provided
to you by aws and aws manages that right
every major cloud provider has their own
managed kubernetes services you have eks
for a uh for aws you have aks for azure
you have gke from google and and many
others right
okay so we're going to install the
eksctl
uh binary because that's what you're
going to use to deploy the cluster once
the cluster is deployed
excuse me we just use
cubectl
basically
okay
so let me set that up
this is the command um i'm posting that
to the team so they can share with you
too
sorry
okay
moving that to
local beam
and
also enabling
bash completion for eksctl
and
that's it
okay
asctl okay that's working too
great
so so far we've only uh downloaded a few
package installed cubectl and installed
eksctl that's what the two main binaries
that we're going to need
to
deploy our cluster right people may ask
oh why why don't we need to install
docker right we're not we're not running
our cluster here on this instance right
we're running that on
we're going to deploy two new ins
actually one new instance to uh to run a
cluster right and the way that
eks works
is that on
uh they they run they manage the control
plane right off of the kubernetes
cluster and we only need to deploy our
worker nodes and that will that's what
we're going to do we're going to deploy
as in c2 instance that's going to work
as our worker node to run our
applications
okay
let's see
no questions so far
oops
download link for
sure
let's see
this is the whole
yeah this is the whole link yeah maybe
if it's
truncated
that's
that's the whole link basically i'm
downloading the cubestl binary if you
want download that from directly from
kubernetes uh uh the kubernetes website
which is kubernetes dot io there is also
a cube ctl there but i'm downloading
that from aws from
an s3 on aws that that they provide
right so that's
that's better i think i don't think
you're going to have any issues if you
download from from the kubernetes.i o
website
but yeah if that doesn't work
with the link please please let me know
okay
so so far we
configure
just to give you like a um
overview of what we've done if if you
just joined the workshop
we deployed the cloud9 instance we
configured an iem role for this instance
and then we downloaded the two files
from a github
uh
that we're going to use to set up the
cluster and then we installed cubectl
and eksctl that's all we've did and
don't worry if you don't understand some
of those names and tools i'm going to
explain that as soon as we start
deploying our cluster and move back to
the slides and i just i just don't want
to waste
too much time um so i want to do the
setup first if
people haven't been able to do that and
and then we go to the slides while the
cluster is is being deployed
okay
let's see here um
so basically what we're going to do
is okay to create this cluster i'm going
to use let me show the files first let
me go back to the files
okay
so the first file that we're going to
use is uh that we're going to interact
with is this dks dash cluster.demo all
right this is going to deploy my cluster
on
aws
so that's why we installed dks that's
going to help me and and here on this
fire you can see the command here
already right
um that's that's what we're going to do
run this command on the terminal uh
of course pointing that to the file that
we have and basically uh uh i'm
deploying a cluster configuration right
and um this is the name of my cluster
this is the region so here you may be
able to change your region if if eks is
available uh on the region that you are
in
right and
it's also a good idea because if we
deploy all
i don't know how many people are
following along and deploying clusters
as well but if we all deploy our
clusters on the same region we might run
out of resources so the way that it
works on aws they have unlimited
resources for
uh availability zones right so inside
the region there's different
availability zones and we might come
we might have some air horse saying that
you don't have enough resources to
deploy that cluster in that region or on
that availability zone because eksctl
they're going to choose
from this from this uh um
this configuration here they are going
to choose which availability zone on us
is one region
they want to deploy a cluster we don't
manage that of course we could we could
add that to the configuration file but i
don't want to add a lot of uh
overhead to the configuration so you
don't need to worry about that
and on this cluster i'm creating a
managed node group right and i'm calling
that manage node group one and i'm
deploying an instance uh of the size t2
small right and here i can say the
minimum size and the maximum size that
means that
my cluster
can
have only one worker node only one
instance and maximum
free right so if i need to increase uh
the number of worker nodes on my cluster
i can easily do that right and if i like
if i can change that to 10 it doesn't
matter what's going to matter here is
the desired capacity right that's what
what's the cluster is going to start
with right if i change that to free for
example then it's going to deploy three
different ec2 instances of the same size
in the node group right and i don't want
that i don't wanna i don't want free i
don't wanna we're only going to use a
small web application
so
i i don't want that i just want one
so that it doesn't i don't need to pay a
lot of money uh for for deploying this
cluster all right this is the volume
size right the hard drive and some
labels the worker uh labels the worker
role right and that basically that's it
right that's that's all that is on my
cluster
so here
i'm going to use this command let me go
to the
site workshop
here is my eks cluster so i just enter
the directory of the uh
of the github project that i just
downloaded again it's it's just if you
haven't
this is
say
hello you like sure
okay
um yeah maybe maybe the chat let me let
me share the
the whole file here
one second some people are struggling
with the commands the first commands
and then give me a few seconds here
let me put that in the drive and um
making sure that
one second
hang on i mean
i should have done that before
sorry about that
[Music]
okay
okay let me share
this file here i created google docs and
i will share the link of the google docs
of all the commands
and
um
and then we can share with everyone
participating so then we can check
let me just
select one-on-one workshop
that quickly
okay
yeah i'm sharing on the google docs um
so if you can share that link with
everyone everyone can see that link
and these are the main commands that we
did to
um
set up cube ctl and ekstl on the cluster
so if you're having any trouble um some
of those are two commands so remember
that and yeah step one step three so
follow that along and check out the
commands there if you're still
struggling after following that let me
know please let me know
um
so i'll i'll move on here and i'll
deploy my cluster and and while that's
that's going on as we're going back to
the slides they can help anyone that's
struggling or answering any questions
right
so yeah as i said right i i want to
create my cluster and to do that i'm
going to use eksctl
uh to do that and the command here is
ekstl create cluster right and i'm
passing a file
which is the one this file here that i
have
so this is the command and i'll add that
to the the spreadsheet as well
so
um so that you can follow along if you
uh if you get stuck or something
um
let me add that to the spreadsheet so
that everyone can see
a gift clone
right
it's like 101 workshop
okay
i'm adding that to the
to the
sorry to the
google docs
just adding that there so that you can
see
okay let's see if that's going to work
yeah like demos or live work crafters
always are always hard
so here i started creating my cluster
and as you can see chaosity always doing
its job it's creating uh subnets it
creates a vpc and then does everything
for me so that makes things easier right
and
um this is what takes a little bit
longer you might face some errors here
uh because of resources if you're doing
on on the same region if everyone's
doing on usc one
what what you need to do basically is
either try on a different region or try
again but change the name of your uh
cluster so that it doesn't uh uh
what what this is doing actually ekstl
is using cloud formation to deploy your
cluster right as you can see here it's
waiting for the cloud formation stack
and all the stuff
and so
if you try to deploy and it didn't work
then if you try to deploy again with the
same name it's going to complain to you
oh there's already some cloud formation
template created with the same name and
let's hope we don't have we don't face
the issues these issues i faced that
on the previous
edition of this workshop that i did
but let's hope not
it seems that no issues so far
um so yeah i'm going to leave that
running here i'm going to go back to the
the slides so that we can continue the
just the explanation of the kubernetes
architecture
and then once the cluster is applied we
come back here to uh to deploy the
applications and and now play along with
the uh attacking the application and all
that stuff
okay
so let me
stop screen
and share the slides again
okay
so yeah we stopped
we stopped here
we stopped here right the kubernetes
architecture
and so as we can see
if you if you're struggling feel free to
ask questions i'll i'll stop and answer
them
uh why i'm explaining a problem don't
worry
as we can see there's two main major
components here there is the kubernetes
control plane it used to be called
master node but for in inclusive
language we don't usually we don't call
it anymore even on the new version of
kubernetes it doesn't say
i think it does say but it's being
deprecated the name master node right so
i'm gonna call it uh from now on control
plane
and so this is on the left side here
with with five five smaller components
on the right side of the slides we have
three worker nodes right
and and the worker nodes are the ones
that we use to deploy our applications
and and today in this workshop we're
deploying only one worker node only one
in c2 instance that's going to function
as as the main
uh the main node for deploying our
vulnerable web application we don't need
three but if we need it as i showed
there with the the max size and the
desired capacity on on the ammo file we
could easily change that there right
okay
awesome awesome yeah yeah i should have
thought about the google docs
um
so yeah on on this on let's look at the
left side first
the cube api server
um the cube api server here in the
middle right we see that that's kind of
a big thing it's the main component one
of the main components of the control
plane
every other component is talking to the
api server and you can see from the
arrows there it's not just talking with
the
uh components from the control plane but
it's also talking to uh the worker nodes
as well right
and the cube api server it's it's
basically a api server and rest api
server if you played with apis before
and that
receives and forwards all the
communication from all the components of
kubernetes right it has a um
basically everything that you
when you type from cube ctl it becomes
an api request or an hp request that
goes to the api server
of your cluster right
on the bottom here on the bottom uh left
we have at cd
and at cd
is
is the main database the data storage of
your cluster right it's a key value
store where all the components of the
equivalence kubernetes cluster is stored
there right
and and so
everything gets saved there as a uh
as an object as a key value store and
then uh kubernetes tries to checks that
and tries to create whatever you told it
to create on the that's saved on that cd
tries to create that on your notes okay
and that's something very important here
because
the
the kubernetes works in the way that
kubernetes works it's called desired
state right so kubernetes is smart
enough right smart enough to see
that
it constantly it's constantly checking
if whatever i told it to create for
example nodes or application or services
whatever i told it to create there on
that cd
it checks
it checks on your nodes and see okay is
this application running already do i
have free replicas of that application
right
if i do okay good that's that's the
desired state if i don't if whatever is
is on that cd whatever configuration is
there doesn't match what's running on
the cluster then okay i need to fix it
right i need they need to match right
and so
so
if let's say i only have one replica of
my application and i need three
kubernetes is going to check that and
it's going to tell the cluster to create
two more uh uh
[Music]
applications two more containers right
from
actually spots but it's going to create
those to match those in lcd so i need to
have three replicas running on my
cluster and it doesn't matter on on on
which worker node depending on your
configuration as well but i need to have
that matching right so it's constantly
checking if you check the logs of
kubernetes it's constantly there's many
different uh components that's
constantly checking to see the desired
state if whatever is on lcd should be
reflected on
on your your whole cluster on your
worker notes right
so you can see here that the api server
and lcd there are two major components
of your kubernetes clustering that's why
you need to protect those and we're
going to talk about
uh security the security part of it and
the best practices as well
but be very careful with those
components right if an attacker has
access to your lcd and they can change
objects there right basically whatever
they change to kubernetes is going to
just follow along just kubernetes is
going okay if you want me to create a
deploy a malicious container i'm going
to deploy a malicious container right
it's it's not
it's not checking who who put that
information there it's only checking if
the information lcd is matching whatever
is created on the cluster okay
and
on the top left here we have the cube
controller manager right
and the cube controller manages exactly
this object that control that has a
bunch of different controllers the pod
controller the service controller and
other controllers that keeps talking to
the api server and checking on that cd
is it matching is it is it oh do you
have the right number of pods oh we have
five here but but we need ten right and
so it's constantly checking that then
it's
specific controller is doing that
the cloud controller manager on the top
right of the control plane is the one
that talks to cloud providers right
that's the reason why kubernetes can uh
work with different cloud providers you
have the cloud controller manager if you
want to use like disk volumes or load
balancers right kubernetes doesn't have
those objects doesn't have uh those
services so you need to use the ones
provided from your cloud provider and
we're going to do that on on eks today
we're going to deploy a load balancer to
expose our application to the internet
okay
good
and on the bottom right
is the cube scheduler it keeps
scheduling exactly the one that tells uh
the worker nodes to deploy the pods
right to
start the containers right it talks to
the cubelet on each worker node to
schedule a pod it can be scheduled like
instantly right in it can be
uh
to cube let's talk to the kubernetes
runtime engine create those spots
okay so those are the five main
components of the control plane
right
now
let's talk to let's let's take a look at
the
the worker notes
here on the
on the right side
there are three main components on each
worker node i have a cubelet i have a
cube proxy
and i have the container runtime engine
okay
so
basically the cubelet is the agent that
runs on each node
that talks to the api server and starts
any any containers and also gets some
statistics and health information about
those those containers right and i'm i'm
talking i'm saying containers here but
it's actually pods but i'm going to
explain that once we move to the next
slides that the smallest unit of
kubernetes is actually pods right
um there is also the q proxy component
that's uh that handles all communication
networking communication inside the
cluster but also externally right with
outside the cluster as well
and the cube
the container runtime engine
which
by default was darker
and
you know there was some
a lot of discussions about when
when they're talking the doctor was
going to be deprecated in kubernetes and
all that stuff i don't know if you heard
about this
this story
but you can still use your docker uh
containers on kubernetes nothing is
going to change it's just that
um
the the reason being that kubernetes to
to be able to run docker kubernetes
developed a kind of another component
called the docker stream
to be able because docker doesn't follow
the
the
oci the open container interface
and kubernetes was created to to run any
oci
uh uh standard containers right
okay so you can deploy that the con the
cubelet is going to talk with the
kubernetes runtime engine and that's
what's going to really create your uh
your containers and run that on your
nodes okay
any questions about this architecture
here so far
so we're going to interact right what
we're doing what we're doing here today
on this workshop we're using the cloud9
instance to talk to the control plane
right we're using that and tell we're
going to tell the control plane to
create some objects for us right we we
just
with the eka ctl command that we just
used that's creating the cluster let me
just quickly see that yeah it's too
creative
um
with the
guest kel command that we use to create
the cluster um
it's kubernetes is doing that and the
way that it works
on eks we don't have access to this
control plane right
because
uh aws handles that for us and and
that's a good thing because you also
don't need to worry about the security
aspect of the control plane all you need
to do you talk to the api endpoint of
your control plane and you tell it to
create uh create applications deploy
containers and all that stuff
um if you're still having uh issues
deploying the cluster if you're having
uh if it's saying that's not available
it doesn't have any resources on that
availability zone
try to change ah change regions right if
it's still not working under different
names if you're still getting errors
i'm gonna show once my cluster is
completed i'm gonna show you the
the outputs of the console and see if
you're getting that but try to change
different uh uh regions it's not working
on the region
sure
uh the oci is the open container
initiative right it's like a standard
for uh
it's standard for creating containers
right
and the
docker
didn't
doesn't apply it doesn't like it's not
in compliance with that standard as far
as i know please please correct me if
i'm wrong
and and so
kubernetes
couldn't couldn't run
docker containers by default
they had to create another software
that's called the docker shin
to be able to do that
so the problem is that
this this component that
allows kubernetes to run docker
containers
is
um
is like
it's maintained by the kubernetes team
uh yeah
sure sure okay sounds good
um so
what's what what's going on is they
don't they didn't want to maintain that
component because that component was as
they call it the docker shim
s-h-i-m
it is is a kind of a like
uh
it's not a good practice what they did
right because kubernetes should be able
to run oci standard
containers by default but unfortunately
docker is not uh compliant with that
so they said oh i know we're not going
to maintain the docker stream anymore
and the docker sheen was going to be
deprecated
right so that's why this caused a lot of
stir on the on the
internet and on twitter a few months
back
because people thought oh maybe like
kubernetes is deprecating docker i'm not
going to be used to use be able to use
my docker containers and credits anymore
what's going on right because pretty
much i would say 90 to 95 or 99 of
kubernetes clusters are running docker
containers and not the other ones right
you can have different runtime engines
you can have the container
the container d cryo or podman it can
there's different ones but since docker
was the default one people usually use
that right and and because docker is is
very well known and people have uh
uh have used docker before even before
kubernetes that's that's what they use
right
so i think that's that's does it with
the oci there is a blog post i think
let me see docker kubernetes
advocated there's a there was a blog
post on the kubernetes website that
talks about that
that whole
that whole issue
um let's see
okay
yes so let me post that link here
and dr sheen faq
okay
let's move on if everybody got the kind
of the overview of the architecture here
let's move on with that
so as i said uh um before right we're
when we deploy a container on kubernetes
we're not deploying a container itself
we're deploying a pod right so the pod
is the smallest unit on a kubernetes
cluster right
the pod can have
one container inside that pod or
multiple containers right so as the
diagram here shows
um right you can have one two or many
right and and the reason being is that
the idea of containers is to run only
one process on that container right so
if i have my application running on my
container and i need something to let's
say collect the logs and ship those logs
to a central location right i don't want
to install that application inside my
application container because that's
going to break the principle and the
idea of containers right so i deploy
another container on the same pod
usually on the same pod and that other
container
talks to my first my application
container and collects the logs from
there to ship it to another location so
that container is usually called a
sidecar container right it can be used
to map to collect matrix logs it can be
used
as a security container as well some
tools some security tools that deploy
the word the way that they work they're
deployed as a sidecar as well
so there's different uh uh um
different usage for that that sidecar
container right and since they're on the
same pod right they share their uh the
name spaces there
um
so other objects that you can have on
kubernetes is a deployment right
you can you can deploy a pod by itself
but
you want to use the features provided by
kubernetes right and
the the way the deployment works it
gives kubernetes or your kubernetes
objects scaling uh updates and rollback
abilities right so let's say if i need
to
create another pod to handle traffic and
there is a lot of traffic on my
application i can easily do that with
deployments if i need to scale up or
scale down if i'm not using all those
containers and and i can save money and
reduce the number of containers that are
running then uh the number of pods i can
do that as well with a deployment right
deployment is just an api a kubernetes
api object right it's not something that
that exists on on the node itself it
only exists inside my cluster it's just
a configuration and the way that they
use there's many different objects that
i'm going to show on the next slide
we're not going to be able to cover all
those objects here but just to give you
an overview okay
and on top of that deployment
we have something called namespaces and
those are different than the the linux
kernel namespaces these are kubernetes
namespaces right and and the way that
the namespaces work here is that they
work like uh um if you're just a logical
separation of different applications
that i have on my cluster right it's
basically folders inside my cluster
right there is no kind of a security
boundary between those namespaces right
so i can have
a namespace for my
uh developer environment a namespace for
my keyway environment and a namespace
for my production environment i can also
have a namespace for my developer team
one and my name is space for developer
team two if they're both using the same
cluster right
so
and we're gonna talk about namespaces as
well here which is another part uh in
another slide
and and on top of the namespaces there's
nodes right nodes is basically the the
server that's running my application so
it can be a vm it can be an ec2 instance
it can be also a
far gate on aws or other kind of
serverless
applications or service serverless
runtimes or workloads
so it can be anything it can also be
runny on prem and can be bare metal as
well there's there's also some uh
some companies that provide kubernetes
running on bare metal
okay and let me go to the
api objects
so there's as i said there's different
api objects that you can create on your
cluster you have a pod as i mentioned
right there is replica set which is is
used by the deployment to replicate your
pods there is demon set stateful set
right the deployment itself as i
mentioned there's service that's used to
expose uh either like a port or or my uh
my application to the world they can
expose that to a load balancer
as well
there's job and chrome job which are
used to uh
just they used the job container it's
basically a pod or a container that runs
only once the job and the current job
it's basically a container that runs
according to the crop tab right i i
i apply the configuration there and it
can join it can run periodically like
every every other minute every other
hour whatever i choose and whatever i
configured on the chrome tab
configuration of that container
um there is also config maps and secrets
my config maps and secrets are usually
used to store information right config
maps is for configuration information
that are not really sensitive
and secrets are supposed to store
secret information right sensitive
information
but
i'm just going to say here that
secrets are not really secret
in kubernetes because the way that
secret works by default
is that all the sensitive information is
stored on that cd
and it's stored on uh encoded as base64
right so you're probably aware that
basic 6664
can be easily decoded and so that's not
really protecting that information
and also
on xcd by default
all the
all the information stored in that cd
is stored in plain text right it's not
encrypted right so there is another
issue there as well so there's different
uh ways that you can
use secrets on kubernetes you can maybe
use like a third-party solution like uh
hashicorp vault or use the
the one from aws as well it doesn't
matter so just be careful if you're
using secrets with kubernetes don't use
the default settings right
apply there's some uh configurations
that you can apply to at least encrypt
your secrets on that city
um yeah there's ingress and many
different objects right and those
objects are all they all work
they can all be applied as a yaml file
and i tell that and apply that to my
cluster using cubectl and and that
depending on what i'm creating on that
file that gets treated in the cluster
exactly because of the desired state
right i don't care how kubernetes is
going to do that i just tell it okay i
want this object created on my cluster
and and then okay apply that to to the
lcd once i send that information via
cube ctl that goes through the api
server and gets stored in that cd right
and now the the controller is checking
that oh something changed here and oh
they want me to create
this
this object okay now deploy this object
and everything happens really quickly
okay
any questions so far
let me see here i think my cluster got
created so i'm just going to talk about
chip ctl and then we're going to go back
to the cluster if anyone's still having
uh
struggling or still having issues please
let me know
so basically the kip ctl as we
we did on the cloud9 instance right is
the cli tool that allows you to control
your kubernetes cluster right
it's it's a config file there is a
config file that
uh can be found on your home directory
under
the cube and i can show you
what's where that's stored on our cloud9
instance right
it's very similar to the docker cli
uh for docker containers let me see
another question here
is an api object like request parameters
to the appropriate api endpoints
request parameters
i'm not sure i understand the question
uh api objects on kubernetes
they are
they're
they're just like different different
objects they have different
uh uh
how can i say functions right
so basically when you talk to kubernetes
and you talk to the api server there is
an endpoint for each each object right
so let's say my kubernetes cluster and
like slash api slash
slash create right so there's different
endpoints everything gets
gets
convert from the api request and it gets
to the lcd
right
once that's stored on that cd and
depending on the which type of object
that gets created on my cluster
right i'm not sure if you can try to
rephrase the question uh
please
so that i can i'll try to answer that
better i'm not sure if i understood
correctly
but but yeah so the syntax of the cube
ctl right it's very similar to the
docker command the docker cli and and
the reason being as well that they did
that so so that people that were using
docker already could easily shift and
start using kubernetes without facing
too many challenges right
so yeah that's it
see yeah it's before we move on let's go
back to our cluster and let me go to uh
the cloud9 instance here
okay
sure
second okay
so you can see um
from the command that i did right create
cluster it did a bunch of things here
creating the cloud formation
and everything and should be uh
should be working right
so to make sure that everything is
working if as i said if you face any
errors if there was something going on
or or there was no not enough resources
either either try to change the name of
your cluster and try again because it
could be just a tape or everything or
the availability zone that eks ctl chose
for you it wasn't uh there wasn't enough
resources and once you try again with a
different name it's going to try in a
different availability zone or you can
just change regions and and do the same
thing and see if that works
unfortunately
i don't know if there is a way around
that if someone that works for aws can
tell me about it but as far as i know
there's
there's no way unless you create your
own
uh
subnets and vpcs and configure that that
you know that there are resources
available
but that can be like a soft limit
from
aws that i'm not very aware of
okay so let me just clear this
see okay good you guys see my screen
is there another question there
okay no questions
so basically
let me do cube ctl get
notes
okay
so i can see here right uh this is the
first command i'm getting all the nodes
that are part of my cluster right and
there's only one node which is this
instance here right that's running
and it's selling the kubernetes version
here um
120
and
yeah it's ready right so the instance is
ready if i go to the aws console i can
see another instance created there as
well besides my cloud9 instance now
right
um
let's see
okay
here on uh
on the
home directory slash dot cube
there are some stuff that was created
the config file right
if i cut that there is some
some information about my cluster how to
access my keys and other stuff right i'm
gonna not gonna show
everything
but basically that's it it's there you
can see that there is uh some
certificates the ip of my cluster and
all that stuff
um one thing that you need to be aware
of on eks
clusters is that by default once i
create my cluster
the api endpoint the
the api endpoint for my cube api server
that's public by default right i know
that's a long url and it's it's hard to
guess
but there are attackers people on the
internet scanning uh the internet for
looking for those api endpoints so if
you don't need that
exposed to the internet be be be aware
of that and make sure that you configure
that to be private and we're going to
see that very soon
okay so now that my cluster is created
we're going to deploy the other objects
uh actually the objects off of my
kubernetes cluster right now my
kubernetes doesn't have anything right
so if i do keep ctl got
parts
no resources found
uh
there is some resources right from they
are the default resources of kubernetes
uh of the eks cluster
right there are some stuff core dns aws
cube proxy running but there is no no
application run right you can see that
they're all running on the cube system
namespace which is the main namespace of
my uh control plane components right
let me see if you've got pods
uh
s or or name spaces right so these can
do like this name space or and as as a
shorter version
right and as i said name spaces are kind
of like
basically folders for organizing stuff
on your kubernetes cluster right and by
default i usually have those four
uh name spaces when i create my cluster
either on the manage or unmanage version
okay
so now let's create the objects right
and let me go to this file here and i'm
going to describe everything that's
there before we apply this uh
this object there
so i'm creating a new namespace on the
cluster object so you can see here and
this is our different every
the way that yama works right every
three dashes here it it's
it's basically a separate file or
separate object but i put everything
together right so that's easy to
uh to understand
so i have one object being created here
that's a name space called
web app right so basically i'm creating
a folder to deploy my web application
this is an our back configuration and
creating a cluster row and a cluster
role binding telling that the
um the service account and i'm gonna
talk about our back and services account
later but basically telling the service
account that i'm going to use to deploy
my web application my my my pods running
on this web app are running as add me
right and and so that's a bad thing and
i'm i'm purposely doing a
misconfiguration on my cluster but
that's for the exercise that's for the
workshop right by default you don't want
to do that you don't want to do that
there's also
a deployment right and i'm using
deployments to
deploy my my web application i'm using
i'm creating like a drupal deployment
here because i'm we're deploying a
drupal web application and you can see
here down below that the specs of the
containers that i'm using i'm
downloading drupal 8.5.0
and since there is no specification of
which container registry i'm downloading
from
that's getting that from docker hub
right so once i deploy that i apply that
object to my cluster
kubernetes knows that okay i don't have
that image here or whatever whatever you
want so
i'm going to download the by default it
uses docker hub to look for images right
unless you want to apply of course
that's not a good practice that's not
something that you want to do because if
someone compromises the docker hub or or
puts a malicious image there then you're
downloading an image to your cluster
right so the best practice is to have
your private container registry and
store images your
approved images there for you to
download on your kubernetes cluster
okay sounds good
so and there is also
a service i'm creating a service here
which i'm going to use services or
objects that
i can use to expose uh
my containers right and i can expose
just like there's different types of
service
the type that i'm creating here is a
load balancer which is going to create
an aws load balancer and
i expose my drupal web application right
which is running on port 80 and it's
going to expose that on a port 80 of the
load balancer as well
so as i said there's different types of
services there is cluster ip there is no
port there is a load balancer and i
think one more
yeah i forgot the other one and no
problem i'll i'll oh i'll remember
and this is basically i'm adding
i'm adding just a kind of a flag here
that i use this is i use this this kind
of
setup to deploy a ctf challenge right so
i have a flag here i'm creating a secret
and i'm storing that secret as a a
flag
named ctf on the cube system namespace
and this is the the the result of the
flag here right the the
the value of the flag and it's basically
base64 encoded it's just a flag that
we're going to practice and try to get
that once we compromise the cluster okay
sounds good so
i i hope you understood all these
objects and we're going to apply that to
my cluster and you're going to see that
that's going to be very uh
quick
let me go back to the
environment
let me go back to that
project that we downloaded from github
and that's where my cluster underline
objects is
yeah just keep in mind that for the
first file
i don't know why i did this but the
first one i used dash and the second one
i use underline so let's see if the
command is correct yeah it's using
underline so this one
so once i do this kubernetes apply
dash f right so dash f means that i'm
passing i'm
feeding it a file and so it's going to
look whatever is in that file and apply
that to the cube the kubernetes cluster
let me just apply that
and you can see that all the objects
that were on that file were created
right the namespace web app
the service account the the deployment
the service and even the secret
everything is created now so if i do now
keep ctll get
namespaces
i can see that there is a web app
namespace is there on the bottom right
if i do tip ctl
get
um
pods
man dash and web apps so now that i'm i
just want some information from a
specific namespace i'm using the the
parameter dash n to tell kubernetes i
only want the pods from this namespace
right
see there's one pod running what happens
if i get this like cube ctl get pods
no resource is found because if i don't
tell kubernetes the cube ctl a specific
namespace
it's going to look into the default one
the default one is this one here at the
top and it doesn't have anything there
that's why it's not gonna find it
right so you need this that's something
that
people that are starting to work with
kubernetes may
may forget and may think oh i just
created this where is it right if you
don't specify anything
then it's all the objects that you
create are going to create on the
default namespace but as you can see
from the uh object that we use here i
created this new namespace and i told to
create all these objects on the web app
namespace right except this one which is
on the cube system okay
see
okay let's see another question
where are these api objects going to do
these get sent to xcd
and then some pulling services check for
new additions resources using apis yes
yes so the api objects they go to at cd
as a like a key value store right so
there is this stored on that cd
and
the controllers
the the cube controller manager with
their controllers they check at cd and
see what change do i need to create this
object oh oh yeah this i need to create
a service or this load balancer or this
pod and then
it talks to other objects like if it's a
pod talks to the cube scheduler and
tells okay create the spot on my cluster
i don't have that on my cluster right
now and i need at cd's telling me lcd is
the source of truth right sdd is telling
me that i need this cluster this object
there so create that for me so some
objects in kubernetes are or like
how how can i say they they have a
physical representation right so for
example
pod
it creates it it creates itself there on
on on the
when it's created on the cluster yeah i
can see it i can see that there is a pod
and there is like something running
there is a container and all that stuff
some other objects are just kind of
how can i say they're kind of you're
more abstract you're there they exist
there the existing kubernetes and stuff
but there is no kind of physical
representation of that object besides
the configuration lcd
right so it's just like uh
some stuff that kubernetes do to to
to
kind of encapsulate that object in some
specific configurations like such as
deployment stateful set it is just a way
for you to
uh to help you deploy uh containers in
like different with different
characteristics right basically that
so yeah i hope that answers your
question if not yeah let me know
okay
so now i have a web application running
and we expose that web application
to the internet via via the load
balancer right
so now
i can get the service
off my web application
right and you see that there is a
service called uh drupal dash svc
load balancer running here and this is
what we need right the external ip
so this is the ip of my web application
that should be running there so if i
click on that if i copy that url and
open on my browser and i'm going to show
you right away
let me share the screen again
change
change here to my other tab
if
okay
here
oops
yeah so you can see here that there is a
drupal
web application set up on on this url
right and i need to install it i need to
configure and that's what we're going to
do right and uh um but yeah basically
okay it's running i'm exposing
this drupal container to the internet
with with only that cluster only that
container right and with the service
load balancer of course if you go to the
aws console where where the load
balancers are you're going to see that
there is a load balancer created there
as well i'll show that later but yeah
so that's what's being used my container
is running inside my cluster my
kubernetes cluster i'm using the load
balancer to expose that and i'm
accessing that through that long url
so don't use the same url that i'm using
because your url is probably different
than life right depending on on where
you deploy your cluster
um
so let me install here i hope that
nobody messes with my
drupal
what i want to do here is choose the
language use the standard one right we
need to configure the web application
and need it running so that we can
exploit it
i'm going to use sqlite which is the
database here
so that i don't i don't need to set
anything
and
yeah it's going to install
and there's some just a few minor
configurations there
but basically we all need to do that if
we want to exploit and and play along
with our
uh
[Music]
exploiting the application right
so dodge coins i can set anything here
like this this doesn't matter this
configuration is just to complete the
the configuration of my website but
but yeah cloud village
thatcom.com i'm not going to use any of
that so don't worry about remembering
the
the the username or password or or
or anything because we're not going to
use that we all we only want to do that
to set up our
um
our
drupal web application
so i'm gonna use just a strong password
just in case that anybody tries to
mess with my uh application
but yeah that's
it
okay
so
[Music]
yeah okay it's fine
so yeah now i see the drupal web
application is running right and you can
see that's working i'm logged in as
admin i can post i can like you can do
anything it's a regular drupal web
application it's just using an outdated
version because that outdated version
has a vulnerability right and now we're
going to uh
now we're going to exploit that
vulnerability
okay
no more questions
so yeah let me go back now to
to the slides i'm going to talk a little
bit about how we're going to exploit it
and the vulnerabilities that we're going
to do and then we go back to this web
application
true
okay
see
change slides you're good
so what we're using today uh um
and as we mentioned in the beginning
right we're using track modeling
to
to attack this this web to see what
vulnerabilities are in the application
and then poc right so that's one of the
things that i do during my daily job
right so analyzing new technologies
especially cloud and container
technologies um
check the possibilities of of
any kind of like a hypothetical attack
and create a threat model for it and
then try to poc it right try to create a
proof of concept for that as well um one
of the things that we like to use is the
miter attack framework right
and as i mentioned the meta tag
framework is is a a very well known
framework on
the
among the infosec community right it's
like a
knowledge base of tactics and techniques
based on real-world scenarios right so
you have the the minor attack
for enterprise you have the mother
attack for linux for windows
and you have even one for cloud which is
now called ias infrastructure service
for for uh the all the cloud major cloud
providers
but we didn't have one for um four
containers and kubernetes until
this year right
so
what uh
what we did was uh there was a um
one
matrix released by microsoft
uh in april last year april 2020
that they they kind of used the miter
attack framework structure of tactics
and techniques this this matrix approach
to uh to create their own their own
matrix like based on the data that they
were seeing on azure on their aks
clusters they created okay so deers are
the techniques that attackers are
exploiting in kubernetes environment
right
and so but that's not an official miter
matrix right a minor project
so in
in december december last year
the the mitre team for uh cloud and
containers they released like they
publish a blog post asking
uh for help for from the community
to collect data about real-world
scenarios and and what attackers were
doing on those environments right so
either
previous attacks that happen real-world
attacks that happens to organizations
such as tesla and um i think there's i
don't recall others now but yeah there's
many others eks as well they used as a
baseline so
they're they're trying to gather real
world data and real-world information or
or honeypot information from what
attackers were doing there
so since we do this uh research on
on a daily basis we had a lot of data
that we reach out to minor to provide
them with that data to help build this
matrix
so the the work started uh basically
last year beginning of this year
and in april this year they released the
official miter attack for containers and
and i i kind of
add and kubernetes as well because
that's not that's not what how mighta
calls it but there are some techniques
here that are very specific to uh
kubernetes environments right
or
orchestrated container orchestration
environments but yeah basically this is
the minor the official minor attack for
containers that was released in uh april
this year
so you can see that there is the the
common tactics there and there is those
those techniques there are very some of
those already existed
on the miter framework but they didn't
have the context of
container environments right so they add
that reference or the technique
specifically or that actor
and and some of the techniques are brand
new they didn't exist before and so
that's that was a kind of a cool project
that that i did that i helped build with
uh with meyer and then there's the link
there with the matrix but it's all
official made matrix uh for the my
attack framework for uh containers is
this one
and
and yeah there's different techniques
here um
different transactors actively
exploiting those environments
on on on 100 parts that we deployed um
it took less than 24 hours for the
attackers to compromise our environment
and we didn't we didn't like publicize
that we didn't we just deployed the
kubernetes environment with a vulnerable
web application and in less than 24
hours the attackers had uh
compromised the cluster right and even
broke out of the cluster and compromised
the the cloud environment that that we
set up the cluster in
and they started deploying
big instances to mine cryptocurrencies
right that and that's usually the end
goal here with docker and kubernetes
environments when attackers compromise
those environments
uh like 90 or 95 of the times the end
goal is to
either
um compromise the already the containers
that are already running or deploy new
containers to mine uh monero
cryptocurrency right that's that's
usually what happens most of the times
okay so what i did with the trap
modeling part was even before this was
done this diagram here was done even
before the miter framework was released
it was done last year
and what i did was exactly create this
model diagram
based based on the the the
microsoft attack made the microsoft
kubernetes track matrix
and and so
i created like a scenario where okay
which are the steps that
an attacker can do to compromise a web
application running on a vulnerable web
application running on a kubernetes
cluster
excuse me
so yeah here we have the initial access
right the web app running in a pod
so we have that already we set up that
already on aws right
and and the web app has an application
vulnerability and you're going to see
that really soon we're going to talk
about the vulnerability that
that
this drupal outdated drupal application
has
and the attacker exploits this rce right
they exploit this this vulnerability and
then they get a shell inside the pod
inside the container right and from
there they can do other things right and
so this is a kind of the diagram that i
created
um to help me
understand what what an attacker was
able to do and and that's when i did the
poc to validate that
and of course then
then that's where this kind of this
workshop came from right from this
diagram there as well
so i can i i don't know if you can see
the whole diagram if it's if it's too uh
too small but i can share just a diagram
link later with you
so yeah attacking kubernetes if we have
set up this
like i call the website dodge coins
right if you have the drupal set up now
and you should see kind of a similar
screen
a screen to that to that stream
okay
okay
so what we're going to do
right what are we going to do today is
exploit this
yes yes i can share the attack scenario
diagram
um i don't have the link handy right now
um yeah someone is asking if i have this
attack scenario diagram uploaded
anywhere sorry um but yeah i do have it
i just don't have the link handy uh with
like a high higher resolution version
but i can share that together with the
slides uh no problem
so so yeah the initial access here right
so that's when we start now attacking
kubernetes and i know it took i'm sorry
it took too long to get here but i
wanted to everyone
follow along and be everybody on the
same page to set up the environment and
so that you can understand the basics of
kubernetes so now that we can start
attacking it right and that's that's
what's important here like unless you
understand the basics now it's just
practicing different scenarios and
different attacks and maybe you can do
that on your own later
um
so
two main uh entry points of a kubernetes
cluster right one of the entry points
here is a vulnerable web application
right and we're going to see
why why is that
this vulnerable web application has an
rce right a remote command execution uh
as you can see the cve from 2018 and
we're going to use that exploit code on
that github
uh to do that to exploit that
vulnerability right
uh other ways that uh kubernetes
clusters got compromised
before was the exposed dashboard so in
previous versions of kubernetes there
was a dashboard that was created by
default that allowed you to kind of
manage your cluster in a uh
in a like
graphic user interface way right
uh but that got deprecated and it's not
uh
it's not deployed by default anymore you
can still do it but it's not it's not
deployed anymore by default and
that that dashboard has some
invulnerability some issues that's how
one of the
[Music]
uh one of the the cluster attacks that
happen a few years ago on a tesla that's
how they compromise their environment
they expose a dashboard
and and so that's not the case anymore
and see even the reason why on the if
you look at back at the kubernetes strap
matrix by microsoft they kind of
deprecated that that technique right
because
since it's not deployed by default let
me go back you can see here as the
initial access exposed dashboard is kind
of deprecated right
there's other options right on the
initial access there is using cloud
credentials compromise container
registries and all that stuff but i'm
going to focus on the application
vulnerability here
there is also the cube api server right
and if the cube api server is exposed
and it's not properly configured right
you can even deploy pods through the the
api server the api endpoints right so so
yeah
it's the same thing with the docker
daemon api right if that's exposed and
there is no authentication there is no
and the person which with access to that
can
um
can have
we can have like uh uh access can reach
the api endpoint
then then they may be able to do some
things or get sensitive information
there right
the cube api server endpoint is public
by default by instant managed services
like eks
um sally asks you the question here do
you have any issues with aws having
vulnerabilities in your clusters um
with this workshop right we're not
we're we're just deploying a vulnerable
cluster and we're compromising it
ourselves we're not stalling any malware
we're not running scans on on aws and
yeah we
we
we had some issues in the beginning but
but like with our honeypots but we
changed the way that we deployed and
also the environments and and yeah uh i
don't think we're gonna have issues with
that this scenario today
so yeah but if you do please let me know
and we're going to shut down everything
later so it's not going to be up for for
uh a whole lot
so that you don't get your your cluster
compromised by like someone else right
we don't want that
okay
so one of the main things
um
one of the main issues that i said is
the api endpoint right reaching the api
endpoint externally uh that can be a
problem you can see two examples here
accessing um on an unmanaged cluster the
api server of kubernetes runs on port 64
for free
and on uh eks it runs on on port 443
right and if i have the url of that api
endpoint i can just do a curve request
to to that url and i can get some
information about my uh my api endpoint
so let's let's try to do that first
before we go into exploiting that let's
try to do that first let me go to the
um
eks
so i'm gonna share my screen here sorry
keep forgetting that
so yeah i'm here on my aws console and i
went to eks the elastic kubernetes
service
and i'm going to check my cluster here
and i can see that i have a cluster
running and it should be at least only
one if if it's a brand new account or
something like that
right and that's my am i the cluster
that we created for this workshop
um
so this is kind of the console of your
kind of your control plane right oh it's
telling me that i'm using an updated
version there's a new version available
i can see my uh
let's see my configuration here right so
this is my api endpoint
and that's
usually exposed by default let's see if
we can if we can open a new tab
you can see that yeah
okay let me show you here we can either
do a curl or or um
or just open a new tab in the browser
but yeah i'm gonna show you here
okay
so yeah you can see here that i got like
an er right
uh let's see api
version
or just
version
oh yeah yeah
so so yeah i got just accessing the url
there i got an error right and i got
like this is kind of a json error and a
403 telling me forbidden user system
anonymous cannot get path slash right
and and okay this is okay i don't have
access to that and that's fine but you
can see that this is api response is
very specific to kubernetes right
i
and and you can already tell
that
by the by the format that there is a
kubernetes cluster running here right
and if i go to slash version which is
usually open to anyone by default
i can see the kubernetes version that's
running i can see
right the go version of my uh of my
kubernetes and the platform and all that
stuff so this is kind of a
uh information leak right
um that
it's exposed by default and
in many eks cluster right if you deploy
the cluster like we did by default with
the default settings it's going to
expose once someone knows this endpoint
of course it's a long url
but you can see that this is running on
eks right and basically what changes is
is this
this kind of uh sequence this string
here right
and so people can try to attackers can
try to
scan the web and scan for uh for any
kind of open clusters that may be
running a vulnerable version or or are
like
exposed by default right so they want to
look for that so yeah be careful about
that
uh
let's see
what else can we do here
let's go back to the
let me go back to the
cloud9 instance now
we're going to
download
the
download the
the exploit that we're going to use and
and
and use it right basically that
so let me grab that again
one second
okay
so this is the url
of the exploit
let me share here with everyone
uh let me share the screen to you
sorry
okay
so yeah this is the github of the
exploit uh for the cve
right in effects uh drupal right 8.5 so
8.50 that's the one that we're using
um just a couple of things here um
before you just kind of
uh
clone this right if you get clone
and and download this to your uh cloud9
you need to have ruby running installed
it should have that on your cloud nine
uh but it might require it might require
some like dependencies
which is a gem and we're i'm going to do
that with you together if if that
happens we just install the dependence
and we can run right so all we need
right now is the the
um
the load balancer url
uh from where your application is
running so let's go back there
let me go to the cloud9
sorry for the switching screens
and that's that's safer
okay
so yeah i'm going to need i'm going to
need that url right so just save that
for later
uh save it like on notepad or something
because you're going to need that for
exploiting the cluster right and you can
you could do that from any other uh uh
machine i'm just going to do the
through the cloud9 because it has
rubbing installed already and so it's
going to be easier for me to do that
uh so
let's see
i'm going to add that command xl to the
google doc
and
[Music]
each clone
let me just
get out of this
okay
so i downloaded the the
xlite which is which is written in ruby
from github and now i can see that here
right
if i take a look at the the description
there basically i just need to run the
uh exploit and set up a target right a
url of the vulnerable drupal application
right and that's the url of the load
balancer that we have already right
so let's try to run that and see if that
works if it doesn't then we install the
dependency on uh on on robbie and should
work
uh as intended
so
yeah
basically your guide on the rv
and
the url of my
load balancer and let's hope that works
yeah it's missing
yeah
in high line seats it's missing a
dependence here cannot load file
highlight import
i think it's suitable you can install
timeline
yeah so another comment let me add that
to the google docs
i added that already there
okay
so it should work now that's
fingers let me just
clear this
fingers crossed
oops
not yet
why it didn't work maybe
open the terminal again just in case
oops
let's dry one more time
see if that works if it doesn't i'll do
from my
machine no problem
oh maybe i need okay
i need the
the path probably
yeah uh
let's try
let me show you from my machine and then
i'll figure out how how to solve that
for everyone
okay
let me
open a terminal here
and i'll share my screen to wait a
second
okay
yeah that works let me share my screen
better
sorry about that
this is the
problem with live
workshops live demos
i'm gonna share my terminal okay
so yeah i
i went to the drupalgetom folder where
where the exploit is right
and because i have the robbie and the
dependencies already installed that
worked already here and basically i did
drupal get on the rb
and uh
with the url of my load balancer right
where my application is running right so
i think there is some issues with the
with the path of robbie um
and on the
cloud9 and we can we can figure out that
soon so let me show you what's what's
going on here
so the exploit is running right is
looking for for the drupal stuff it's
it's collecting so you can can get
information about my uh
my web application where it's running
and all the stuff and and i get a shell
here right
so
let's see um
with mine
see it's running as the user www data
from the
web server or where these um
this container is running right
um
let's see
see
see i can see from the files already
that right
if i've if you've known drupal before
and know the file structure of drupal
you can see that there is a drupal uh
application running
and
yeah so this is already i'm inside where
are where i am right now with the
exploitation of of the the web
application um in a shell
inside the pod that's running the drupal
container
right um
so
what else can we do here right what else
can we uh
can we see
how do i know that this is a a
cluster like this is running on a
cluster right
so some things that
can help you understand
um where is it running um the
environment right it's checking the
environment variables right
i do and i just will i see a lot of
environment variables right i don't want
all of them
so
let me do
and
find grab
i
cube
can we do that
oh now i see there is a lot of
kubernetes environment variables and you
can see them all together here and i can
see
the the ip address of my
uh of my api endpoint my api server
right you can see the port that's
running right and so there's a lot of
information here so these already
telling me that this this is running on
a kubernetes cluster right
let me just add that
and just add that to the sorry to the
google docs
um
and
thank you
what other
what other things that i can do here
right i'm inside a kubernetes spot what
can i do what else can i do right it's
not just like it's it's running inside a
container right
and and
um but what else what information can i
have
another thing is
that
kubernetes stores
their uh service account tokens on each
on every pod
and that account token is used for the
pod to talk to talk back to the api
server right and so
if i go to any they are all on the
always on the same location on the same
uh directory
so if i go here to
um
[Music]
run
secrets
i think i need to increase the font a
little bit
secrets
kubernetes.i yo
service account
see if it's going to show me i don't
know if it's because of my shell no
see
[Music]
yeah my show is not great i should
probably deploy a new chair okay yeah
now i can see it here
i can see there's free files here right
the certificate
the namespace which is basically where
where the the
vulnerable web applications running and
the token right and this can be used for
me to talk to the api server
there is another tool that can be used
as well
which is also it helps uh
getting information about the
the containerized environment
and this tool is called in my container
we post this
i'm gonna post that to the google docs
and step nine we're going to
look at the mi container
so what we're going to do is use
download this tool
to the
to the
bar that i'm running
and execute it right
so let me
go back here
one second
uh
where is it
okay
um yes let me share that
so
let's see if that's going to work i have
the command somewhere here
yes uh
basically
actually i want this one
um
yes i posted that to the google docs so
that everyone can follow
i'm going to try to do that through my
shell
it worked so basically i went to the
folder i used curl to download the
binary of my container from the github
right
and yeah change it uh
permissions there and execute it right
so you can see this is the output this
is the output of the
mi container tool and it shows that the
container runtime is cube
it shows it has namespaces pid namespace
through username space false it shows if
there is some uh if there are any
protections your um
linux security module is activated like
app armor or
uh
sc linux or sako right so you can see
that the app armor is unconfined
there is some capabilities that you can
see here as well
and also syscalls that are blocked so i
know that as as well
um so this gives me a lot of information
already right so um
it's it's good for an attacker to kind
of do like a recon
of the internal environment right
i can even see if i can curl
i think i can even curl from here
yeah see the same thing that i uh
nope not gonna work um so the same thing
that i did on accessing the tab
uh the url i'm doing that from inside
the pod and since those are environment
variables it's going through it's
getting those and getting the kubernetes
the cluster information right
so that's interesting another thing that
i can do
is you probably heard about the
api metadata right the instance metadata
from
from
cloud providers right they all have one
aws has one google has one and an azure
as well
so from a compromised pod
if that's enabled you can reach the api
metadata as well
and i'm not gonna show my
not gonna show my api keys but i can
show you some stuff that works let's see
where is it
one second
and
yeah let me get okay let me grab that
first
let and find my
my cheat sheet here sorry about that
where is it okay
all right okay i'm not finding that so
yeah uh i'll show the the api metadata
soon don't worry let me just
another thing that you can do is
you can from the pod that you're
compromised right you can talk to the
api server too
and as i said here like i i just did the
curve to the api server but if i do it
like
just slash api
you can see that i got 403
uh error as well right so i got
forbidden because i'm not sending any
kind of
uh authentication on any kind of token
it's not working
but as i showed that there is some
credentials some service account
information the certificate and the
tokens inside the pod that i compromised
i can use that to
feed feed into my car request to talk to
the api server
let's see
let's go back there
so i'm going to create two environment
variables here let's see if they work
i'm going to create the token
environment variable that's
using
getting the token from that directory
and the namespace as well getting the
namespace from from that directory and
now
now i'm going to
do a curve request
but with that request i'm sending
the header authorization their token
to
[Music]
to this uh um
to this api right api server
ah
didn't work
i maybe some
maybe it didn't work my
no
yeah
so i need to copy probably copy that
fine
so fine
yeah i'm going to show my token that's
fine we're almost i think we're
almost at the end now
i don't know if you're gonna have time
to cover everything
but yeah let me try to run that again
instead of token i'm going to
send that here right
let's see
uh unauthorized
hmm
something changed
it's not working
okay
no problem there
it's fine
let's go back to
slides and i'll figure out what's going
on
okay
yeah
so let's see where we are right now
on the
slides
okay
so
we we've done the reconnaissance we
hope this light's not showing yet
someone adds lines
can you see these lines on my screen on
the screen
okay thank you
so yeah we did we did some internal
reconnaissance we inspected the
kubernetes environment we inspected the
environment variables right and and the
service account token we even used a
tool from outside right externally on
github downloaded that tool and executed
uh
yes yes probably yeah there is some
probably some issues i'll check it out
soon i just don't want to
get stuck because we're almost
almost out of time and i want to
complete that but i'll i'll take a look
if we have more time
um
yeah so we did an overview of that right
there is many stuff that you can do here
on uh on your container
there is also a possibility of doing
because the way that this
uh cluster is configured
there is also a possibility of of doing
even like a post
post exploitation or persistence on the
cluster via a privilege escalation right
so there is this technique uh posted by
duffy cooley who works at uh isilvalen
now he used to work at apple
where he created he posted this
kind of command using cubectl
to deploy a
a container
with with like the privileged container
that has access to the worker node right
um and and on the left the right side
here is the kind of the structure of the
json format that he is using to override
uh that container that he is deploying
basically
what what's happening here and and he's
using like um
hosts pid equals true right he's using
the the privilege container through as
well as the security context he's um
he's doing a lot of uh uh
like different techniques to access the
the worker notes right
and and and that's one of the ways to to
do that and
how that happens because i'm allowed
with with that service account that we
created which is uh um
which is giving me a lot of permissions
um
i can i can do that i can deploy a new
port and that's one of the one of the
ways of escalating privileges in a
kubernetes cluster is deploying a
privilege pod on the cluster if i have
missions to do so right of course i
would need to download and install cuba
ctl on that pod first to run it and do
the privilege escalation if we have time
we can try to do that as well
um that can be a little
kind of
tricky on managed clusters because some
the way that
they they handle
those privilege escalations
but but yeah let's see if that works
soon
um
let me talk about the defenses before
before we do some other attacks
otherwise we're not gonna have time
right
how can i protect my cluster from
attackers right isn't kubernetes secured
by default and where do i start right
um
basically we can see that kubernetes is
not secured by default by by many
reasons right so let's take a look at
some different uh things that you can do
to protect your cluster
um
one of the basic things right is taking
a look at when you installed your
cluster and these this applies only to
unmanaged cluster where you have access
to the to the control plane
um but one of the things is it's just
integrity monitoring right understanding
what files are created when we install
kubernetes uh the recommended ownership
and permissions and those are from the
cis kubernetes benchmark
and if if you have the integrity
monitoring set up on that
node anything that changes on those
files either permissions or or or
ownership then you should be alerted
right something suspicious is happening
because usually those don't change very
often and those are the recommended
permissions
the cis kubernetes benchmark if you
haven't heard about it is like a
very extensive documentation with best
practices for setting up your cluster
on uh on kubernetes environments and
setting up playing configuring it
correctly
there is also another kind of
a recent document that was published by
the nsa
called the
kubernetes hardening guidance i think
it was released a couple days ago so
it's pretty recent
but
as far as what i looked from the
document has
had some issues right uh they talk about
pod security policies which is something
that we're going to talk about soon but
those are are being deprecated or
deprecated already
um they they don't mention much about
the
encrypting at cd right which is the
database of kubernetes they only have a
small example at the end
and they're using the docker files with
the tag latest which i don't think it's
a good idea using the latest stack and
that's something that you learn when
using containers so yeah i think the the
cis benchmark document is a better one
to use for deploying your your cluster
securely
um there's also the same thing with the
worker nodes right it's just different
files that are installed on the worker
nodes with with different ownerships and
that's from the recommendation from the
cas benchmark 1.51
there might be there might be a newer
version
but yeah take a look at that on the cis
benchmarks website
uh i talked about keep system uh
namespaces already and and how they can
be uh
dangerous
like
as i said there is no
security boundary between namespaces
right
so the cube system namespace which is
the main namespace of your kubernetes
cluster and it's like a inception right
kubernetes uses kubernetes to run
kubernetes um so all the the main pods
of your uh control plane
are on that coupe system namespace and
so if an attacker has access to those
then then it's it's likely that they can
do a lot of damage right
so be careful with that cube system
namespace you don't want to give access
to
that namespace to every user on your
cluster and
the idea is that you can use our back
which is row based access control to
protect that namespace from being
accessed
i already talked about the api server
how that shouldn't be exposed and how we
can get some information from from the
api server and see if there is a
cluster running
right
um
yeah there is some information that you
can get writing some comments if you
have access right in this case we don't
have access to the control plane right
shell access so
we can't see the configuration of the
api server
but but yeah you can do that if you do
if it's an unmanaged cluster
um the cubelet right we talked about the
cubelet on the
architecture diagram it's the agent that
runs on each node of your cluster right
make sure that all containers are
running in the pod
and uh two main security settings for
the cubelet is restricting cubelet
permissions and rotating the cubelet
certificates there is another thing
that there was a blog post that i
published earlier this year
talking about how attackers are using a
cubelet exploit to compromise
different clusters
me see if i do yeah
so the way that it works just as a a
quick overview and i'll post a link for
the blog here
and
it's not like i'm not trying to promote
anything it's just that's a technical
blog on what we've analyzed from a very
famous uh
actor
the way that they do is they compromise
your environment and once inside your
environment they scan the your whole
entire network
for uh kubernetes clusters running
inside your network right and and they
specifically target the cubelet right
with a tubelet exploit that's being
known uh
for a while okay
so take a look at that blog post if you
if you uh if the um
if they can share the link but but yeah
there is something that's happening on
uh on the y in the wire as well
as i said the kubernetes benchmark is a
guidance for establishing secure
configuration parser for kubernetes um
there is over 120 security checks for
your kubernetes cluster and it has been
developed by uh
cloud native and kubernetes security
professionals with much more experience
than than i have so rory mccoon from
aqua security and reeves
lisa rice from isovalent and many other
contributors right and there's also
specific ones for eks and gke and i
think there is one for aks if not
already
so because the way that the manage
services work they they are a little bit
different a little bit different than
the standard the unmanaged kubernetes so
yeah it's better to take a look at the
specific documentation for that and
that's i think that's the best uh
guidance out there for protecting your
kubernetes clusters
let's see
um if you don't wanna
if if you don't want to run yeah
and if you don't want to check your
benchmark
uh
manually right because it's a long
document it has a lot of tracks that you
need to do and the way that the
benchmark works is that you have um
you have
this the setting that's recommended okay
here's the setting
then it has how to check if the set if
that specific security setting is
properly set up
and then if not set up it has another
command for you to run to change that
setting to the proper
like configuration right so the
benchmark is a pdf file it has a lot of
stuff and like many uh
best practices configurations right but
it's very hard to do that manually and
especially if you have multiple clusters
that's gonna be properly probably
unfeasible for you to do right so aqua
security which is also a company that
that works with a container security uh
products they they provided they created
this tool called cubebench which is open
source and it's free for everyone to to
use
that they check whether kubernetes
deploys securely or not right you can
validate it against your cisco bernat's
benchmark right and it's developed in
gold so it's open source and let me post
the link here
uh
on
from github
to revenge
i think there is
a bash
yeah
okay uh so you can use that right so i i
just have an example here i don't know i
don't think we're gonna have time to run
cube bench on on our own cluster but
it's very easy to do that and you can
see an example of an output here showing
that my cluster my uh has a lot of uh
vulnerabilities or or maybe like it
failed a lot of
best practices from the cis benchmarks
right a lot of fails and warnings and
whatnot and it checks everything from
the masternode the api server the lcd
and worker nodes as well so it's
interesting too
if you if you have closer running on
your organization and you want to see
um their status and then how they look
if they were configured or not it's a
good tool to to use and get a quick
overview of the uh if they're compliant
with some best practices from the
benchmark
um other stuff that you can do is use
some image scanning right
before you deploy your containers on
your cluster the idea is to
scan them for vulnerabilities or or
outdated dependencies and there's
different image scanning tools uh
out there i'm not going to talk about
them there there's different open source
and and
enterprise ones uh all those here are
either free or open source so you can
take a look at those um there's even
like a native docker scan command that
you can use now which is based off a
snake
but yeah there is different others
okay now
you scan the container image and you
deploy that image on
your cluster right but how do i know
that someone has compromised my cluster
some compromised that container that
thought right
that where that's when the the cloud
native runtime protection comes in right
and and probably if we had like a
tool such as lake falco which is an open
source to israel that belongs to the
cncf now it was donated by cystic
and
we it probably would detect some of the
attacks and and the
uh
shell that we got inside the container
right
so what falco does is falco parses linux
kernel syscalls at runtime right it's
using a technology called ebpf
extended berkeley packet filter which is
kind of a
technology that many uh
container security
companies are using
to create their own uh their own tools
their container security tool strength
and it has a lot of visibility on the
system so you don't need to install
agents and
and like
mass
mess with the container deploys
sometimes deploy side cars and all that
stuff
so falco is a real engine right it has a
easy and powerful powerful view room
engine you can create your your own
rules for your vulnerabilities uh it
generates alerts based on the trap
detected i'm even using the
the falco sidekick t-shirt today that i
got as a as a contributor to the falco
project
and it detects unexpected behavior on a
cluster right and the sidekick is
another project that runs with falcon it
gives you better kind of
visibility on on on what falco's seen on
the
logs and everything
um
here we're almost out of time but yeah
there is other settings that you can
apply to your pods right of course cpu
and memory is limiting resources to
avoid denial of service that's something
that you can do you can apply a security
context as well there's a different set
of of
of settings that you can apply on a
security contest some of those are are
here
and as i said the the linux uh security
modules right there the kernel features
second by pr more and less linux can
also be used to apply that to your
kubernetes be careful because docker has
some default uh profiles for those for
app armor for example and secomp but
when you use that on kubernetes
kubernetes doesn't inherit that from
docker so you need to apply that as well
and
yeah pod security policies is something
that got deprecated it's not being used
anymore
it was a way to apply the security
context as a whole on a cluster level
and there is new features now new tools
that you can use some alternatives such
as oppa gatekeeper or kyverno which are
open source tools as well that you can
create policies as code to say okay only
deploy this container if it doesn't have
any high or critical vulnerabilities
right
uh there is a a
a new pod security now i forgot to
update this slide but there's a new pod
security it's not psp but there's a new
version that's being implemented by the
kubernetes seek off and seek security
team right there is a it has been
approved already
um yeah i won't have time to talk over
our back and at cd network policy and
yeah let me finish with the basics and
i'll share those lives with you
and if you want to talk about those
other things our back uh network
policies and audit logs we can chat
later i i'm i'm available on on social
media twitter or linkedin
but basically what i wanted to give you
here is just an overview of kubernetes
an overview of the the security issues
and also an overview of how to secure
your cluster right it doesn't mean to be
it's not an extensive
uh workshop it's not an in-depth
workshop so keep that in mind um the so
i just want to leave you with with a few
a few basic rules with kubernetes right
uh first thing is update your
environment version early and often as i
said there's new versions being released
uh
very frequently now three times a year
and the version 1.22 is the most
up-to-date one uh recently that was
released recently
don't use the cluster admin user for
your daily work right
treat it like root right so the reason
being why why we got to uh exploit that
vulnerability and then uh get a shell on
the quad and then do bad stuff on the
cluster was because
the service account of that pod had too
many permissions right you can even
deploy new pods and escalate privileges
and all that stuff
so be aware of that
if you can use managed kubernetes
services such as aks eks or dke because
they have better security defaults and
you don't need to worry about the
control plane because they care they
care they take care of that for you
and as i said check out the cis
kubernetes benchmark for more security
best practices
uh i hope you enjoyed this workshop
there's some references here and i can
share the uh the whole
command list that i use and you can try
to replicate that on your environment
and i'm sorry if some of the comments
didn't work but i'll take a look and
make sure that's fixed and before i
share with you so yeah